so herzlich willkommen zur heutigen
sitzung ganz zu beginn wollen wir sie
noch mal auf den workshop hinweisen mit
peter van een wagen der am 15 november
stattfinden wird und sie sind herzlich
eingeladen sich dafür anzumelden bzw 1
kurzem motivation hier einzutragen und
dieses blatt also einfach name vorname
in der mitte
wenn sie interesse haben eine kurze
motivation also irgendwie ich schreibe
darüber eine arbeit oder ich habe das
schon besucht oder ich bin irgendwie
also aus irgendeinem grund und dann dann
wäre wenn wir genug plätze haben können
sie gerne daran teilnehmen lass es
einfach mal hier durchgehend der findet
also am 15
und november statt von 10 uhr bis 11 30
und im anschluss gehen wir mit ihm noch
mittagessen und sie könnte dann auch
mitkommen wenn sie interesse haben und
du wolltest aber was dazu sagen
die wirklichen leben hat also das wird
eigentlich so ablaufen dass wir ihn
eigentlich so querbeet einfach fragen
stellen zu sagen philosophischen werke
vor allem hat zur freiheit feminismus
und das heißt selbst wenn sie sie können
auch einfach nur mitglied und zu stellen
das sagen
das sollte sich jeder fragen überlegt
aber das ist also ich selber hab damals
auch mit presse teilgenommen an so
workshops die ist gar zum
philosophischen kollegen darüber dass
über das thema personen
und mich hat es sehr weiter gebracht
weil es nur das ganz anders ist mit den
leuten dann wirklich face to face
man lernt auch richtig wie man sich in
so eine debatte verhält wie man sich
jemand vielleicht gedrängt und so weit
wie man gezielt fragen stellt und das
war total drauf schuss reicht also ich
kann natürlich nicht entgehen zu lassen
und wie gesagt dann im wagen ist
momentan einer der führenden philosophen
im bereich analytische philosophie und
vor allem analytischen metaphysik also
da gibt es kaum einen moment so sie
begegnet dort einer lebenden legende
kurz gesagt und wenn sie nur mal auf den
vortrag hören wollen dann nehmen sie an
der tagung teil gibt es jemand von ihnen
der noch gerne dieser tagung teilnehmen
würde die wir auch organisieren und andy
der workshop angebunden ist und der die
sich noch nicht eingetragen oder
angemeldet hat für diese tagung dann
schreiben wir hier nämlich nochmal die
internetadresse hin
ich glaube es war freedom die thermen
ist glaube ich www.net das ist sie
glaube ich diese adresse freedom die
terminals und punkten nett und dann
können sie sich da mit einem
anmeldeformular einfach anmelden falls
es nicht getan wir haben sehr viele
studentische anmeldungen bekommen und es
ist sehr freundlich wir wollen nämlich
vor allem studenten und studentinnen als
zuhörer gewinn weil das er direkt an
dieses seminar angeknüpft ist diese
veranstaltung hier
ansonsten hat jeder sich eingetragen die
teilnehmerliste gibt es von ihnen noch
jemand der noch nicht angemeldet ist
dann schreiben sie als genau am see e
mails bekommen die rund mails bekommen
nicht komisch dann wäre also sich
eingetragen hat in die anmeldeliste aber
keine bekommen hat schreibt mir einfach
noch mal eine e-mail und dann korrigiere
ich die falsche e mail die ich
offensichtlich eingetragen haben aber
ansonsten haben sie ihren rund mails
bekommen und auch die zusammenfassung
und die app kennen sie ja sowieso auch
und da finden sie auch alles doppelt so
zu sagen das ist gar nicht nötig dass
sie im grunde e mail bekommen müssten so
zur heutigen sitzung wir haben uns heute
viel vorgenommen
dieser nette herr hier steht mal wieder
im zentrum harry ist in princeton an der
princeton university beschäftigt war
davor in anderen universitäten
ich habe ihn auch mal selbst besucht den
fenstern ein ganz netter alter herr der
sich da also zwei stunden zeit genommen
hat und hierzu gehört habe was ich da an
ihn heran geredet habe und also sehr
sehr netter älterer herr und wir wollen
ihn auch mal nach münchen bringen aber
es hat leider nicht geklappt kommt immer
was dazwischen
jedenfalls ist mir ganz ganz wichtig und
er hat eben einmal diesen aufsatz
geschrieben
früher auf der irland die konzerte von
person und der ist in deutschen auch
übersetzt
verfügbar in dieser anthologie die von
monika bezler kennen sie die monika
bezler professor monika bezler ist eine
professorin hier für praktische
philosophie
frau professor bachelor hat das
herausgegebene sammlung von wichtigen
texten von harry wörz die auch ins
deutsche übertragen wurden und das ist
eben der originaltext und wir lesen weil
es ein bachelor seminar ist die texte
sofern sie auf deutsch vorliegen auf
deutsch und wir wollen jetzt noch mal
ganz kurz zurück kommen in der ersten
hälfte dieser sitzung auf diesen text
und haben eben diese fragen die sie auch
schon von der letzten sitzung kennen wir
haben jetzt einige dieser fragen schon
behandelt wir können mal kurz zu
abklappern also die erste frage haben
was kritisiert er an diesen gängigen
theorien der person des trosses person
begriff straßen sagte eine person ist
ein individuum das träger von mentalen
und physikalischen kreditkarten sein
kann und dann sagt harry frankfurt das
ist viel zu weit weil tiere
die haben auch mentale prädikate die man
ihn zu schreiben kann freude angst und
so weiter und so fort
und das muss deswegen auch nicht die
person sein das heißt wir müssen um die
person bestimmt das wenige was eine
person zu einer person macht müssen wir
im mentalen noch ein bisschen näher
hinschauen und dürfen nicht nur generell
von mentalen akten sprechen sondern
müssen wir gerne spezifischen mentale
nackt in den blick nehmen und diese
mentale akt ist der wille oder genauer
genommen die struktur des willens die
reflexivität des willens und darin meint
frank wird das eigentlich personale
entdecken zu können so neu ist diese
these nicht muss man fairerweise
dazusagen schon der spätantike philosoph
augustinus den sie vielleicht auch schon
mal irgendwie mitbekommen haben
augustinus der hat auch schon so was
gesagt dass der wille reflexiv ist dass
sich der wille zu sich selbst verhelfen
egal er hat es jedenfalls hat es
jedenfalls masse portiert dargestellt
dann haben wir uns gedanken gemacht was
ein mann tun ist und wir sind auch schon
mal auf diese koalitionen zu sprechen
kommen auf diese hierarchie auf dieses
problem noch nicht dass man immer höhere
koalition bilden könnte da komme heute
noch drauf und ganz wichtig ist auch die
frage nach dem zusammenhang von
vernünftigkeit personalität und
willensfreiheit also wieder vernunft mit
ins spiel kommt und ganz zum schluss
frage 78 das ist so der letzte text den
wir hier an die wand werfen wollen
dieser punkt führt eigentlich zum
nächsten text schon hin
der frage nach alternativen
möglichkeiten genauer gesagt führt er
zurück weil dieser text den wir jetzt
gerade
später geschrieben wurde als der text
über alternative möglichkeiten die mir
in der zweiten hälfte dieses seminares
diskutieren und ja ich glaube wir können
einfach jetzt mal hier noch mal kurz ein
bisschen durchgehen
also ja ich lese mal vor dieses zitat
was wir in der letzten sitzung nicht
mehr behandeln konnten er sagt also
wenig nun behauptet dass das wesentliche
moment des person sei nicht der vernunft
sondern im will liegt so will ich damit
natürlich nicht unterstellen dass ein
wesen ohne vernunft eine person sein
kann denn allein dank ihrer frucht ist
eine person fähig sich ihres eigenen
willens kritisch bewusst zu werden und
koalitionen zweiter stufe zu bilden
daher setzt die villen struktur eine
person voraus dass sie ein vernünftiges
wesen ist also wille und vernunft sind
beide sehr wichtige bestandteile
hier gibt es wieder diese große debatte
die mittelalter stattgefunden hat
zwischen volunta rissen und intellekt
listen die frage ist immer wo liegt
jetzt das entscheidende kriterium für
willensfreiheit in der vernunft oder im
villen und mir scheint dass marco bitte
korrigiere mich dass frankfurt da gar
nicht so sehr partei ergreifen möchte
sagt es muss eine verwobenheit
stattfinden der wille muss vernünftig
gebildet werden aber es ist dann
natürlich der wille als reflexiv wille
der entscheidend ist wie würdest du dir
dass du darauf antworten auf die frage
was ist jetzt ist jetzt frankfurter wohl
und er ist in intellektuellen ist hast
du da so eine meinung dazu
hat er hier schon ein ausgewogenes
gesenkt es sehe ich aus als die
vernünftigkeit scheint auf alle für den
notwendigen bedingungen zu sein aber
eben auch nicht hinhalten vernünftigkeit
geht nicht notwendig immer schon mit
einem solchen flexiblen einher
aber ist die notwendige bedingungen
dafür seien reflexiven genau die
flexibilität als reflexivität er künftig
und insofern ja zur kirche widersetze
man muss natürlich auch immer aufpassen
dass man von willi und von der vernunft
nicht wie subjekten spricht geldes liebt
das neckt das bild einfach mal das war
sagt der wille tut das und die vernunft
das natürlich tut der wille nächsten die
vernunft nicht sondern die person tot
war wille und qua vernunft im
wechselspiel habe ich denke es ist es
wird es ein ganz enges wechselspiel von
wille und vernunft und ich glaube du
hast zu recht auf diese reflexivität
hingewiesen
die das entscheidende ist gelesen aber
weiter die unterscheidung zwischen einer
person einem triebhaften warten lässt
sich am unterschied zwischen zwei
drogensüchtigen verdeutlichen wir wollen
annehmen dass die physiologischen
bedingungen die der sucht zu grunde
liegen in beiden fällen gleich sind und
dass beides süchtigen unausweichlich
ihren periodischen verlangen nach der
droge erliegen
einer von beiden hasst seine sucht und
kämpft unablässig verzweifelt aber
erfolglos gegen ihre macht er probiert
alles wovon er meint es könne ihn
befähigen sein verlangen nach der droge
zu überwinden
aber dieser wunsch ist zu mächtig er
kann ihm nicht widerstehen und am ende
bleibt jedes mal das verlangen sieger
über ihn er ist ein süchtiger
widerwillen hilflos der gewalt seine
eigenen wünsche preisgegeben
als wenn man muss sich das so vorstellen
hier gibt es eine person die hat oder
person ist die frage nach wie vor als
ein mensch der hat auf einer ersten
stufe einer willens stufe erster ordnung
primäre will uns tendenzen kann man
sagen widerstrebende wünsche und er
verhält sich dazu irgendwie auch aber
offensichtlich nicht so dass er
handlungs wirksam diesem spiel in dieses
spiel der willens tendenzen erster stufe
eingreifen kann die koalition zweiter
stufe werden nicht richtig ausgebildet
sie führen nicht dazu dass er auf deiner
ersten stufe sich wirklich entscheiden
kann also man könnte es vielleicht so
machen dass es erstens und dass zweitens
und die haben wir am a und b das sei
jetzt mal willens tendenzen die sich
wieder streiten und dann ist die frage
kann man sowas wie c ausbilden was dann
irgendwie partei ergreifen kann und 0
wäre dann sagen die handlung das dann
eines von beiden und eine handlung
überführt werden kann marco ist es so
kann man das so sich vorstellen mit
diesem wellnesshotel zweiter stufe also
wir haben hier willens tendenzen erster
stufe wünsche die sich wieder streiten
könnte im konflikt liegen können a oder
b und was wir machen müssen um willens
frei zu werden ist oder im stärksten
seine freizeit ist von einer zweiten
stufe aus willens tendenzen auszubilden
die sich reflexiv auf eine oder mehrere
dieser option beziehen und zwar so dass
eine diese option dann zu einer handlung
überführt werden kann
das war also der unterschied
grün 2 hat auf der einen seite
munition zweite spiel für die braven auf
der habenseite also wenn diese position
20 prozent mehr genau dann wenn man in
einem bestimmten wohnung also den wunsch
hat einen bestimmten sinn zu haben und
mir scheint schon dass diese
drogensüchtige in diesem sinne position
zweiter stufe daher wünscht sich dann
andere bei wünsch ist ein wille ist nur
ist ja nicht wirklich willens frei weil
es nicht an handlungs wirksamer wunsch
er verhält sich dazu
er wäre vielleicht willensschwach könnte
man das sagen also willensschwäche es
gibt ja dieses phänomen der accra sie
dass man also durchaus ein willen bildet
aber nicht in der lage ist diesen willen
der auch auf einer zweiten ebene
gebildet werden kann
in die handlung hier zu überführen
vielleicht etwas wie accra sie eine
weltsprache person genau weil er eben
deswegen eine person weil er eben auf
einer zweiten stufe an villen aus der
sich darauf beziehen
ja das ist denke ich durchaus eine
möglichkeit wie sehen sie die rückfrage
an die teilnehmer teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer ist es nach frankfurt eine
person dieser strömung süchtige hier der
am ende eben nicht handeln kann
nach den kriterien von frankfurt was
würden sie sagen
die
[Musik]
hat noch eine weitere meldung dazu
rechtsfähigkeit traum
auch die gesetzgebung wie die funktion
vor dass man seine eigene freiheit
es ist auch kein
da ist noch eine meldung dazu
[Musik]
ein
in bewegung setzen
wir haben
eine welt abgestimmt werden
was also ist er nicht sagen
[Musik]
also entscheidend ist jedoch dass er
dass man offensichtlich in der lage ist
sich mal reflexiv auf diese wünsche zu
beziehen
das ist schon mal ein großer fortschritt
gegenüber einer situation wo diese
zweite stufe gar nicht existiert wo man
nur zum spielball dieser unmittelbar in
clean ihren willens tendenzen ist und
ich glaube lesen man das nächste zitat
wird es jetzt auch noch hier
die sache noch ein bisschen weiter
erklärt sagt der süchtige wider willen
hat einander widerstreitende wünsche der
ersten stufe also a und b er möchte die
drogen nehmen und er möchte sich doch
zugleich davon zurückhalten sie zu
nehmen über diese wünsche erste stufe
hinaus hatte aber noch eine position
zweiter stufe
er steht dem widerstreit seiner wünsche
die droge zu nehmen und auch von ihr
abzulassen nicht neutral gegenüber er
möchte dass der zweite wunsch also b und
nicht der erst also der besa die droge
nicht zu nehmen
und da sei die droge zu nehmen dass der
zweite wunsch und nicht der erste wunsch
sein will ist er möchte dass sich der
zweite wunsch wirkungsvoll durchsetzen
also praktisch von b zur handlung
durchsetze und den zweck abgeben den er
durch das was er wirklich gut zu
erreichen als es offensichtlich ganz
wichtig dass wir uns dass wir uns nicht
neutral gegenüber diesen willen stufen
erster ordnung verhalten man kann dies
natürlich fragen sind koalition zweiter
stufe normativ enthalten sie mir so eine
wertende komponente als würdest du sagen
marco kann man das sagen in der
freiheits debatte spielt der
normativität eine rolle also so so
wertigkeit wäre das vielleicht auch der
unterschied dass auf der ersten stufe
keine normativität keine wertung richtig
erfolgt dass es hier nur das skript tief
wären hier so etwas wie evaluiere
dimensionen spiel kommen kann auch noch
warten
die phänomenologische beschreiben das
man schon wo er glaube ich schon also
versucht so ein bisschen solche wonisch
strukturen zu beschreiben und das wie
immer einjährigen mit einer gewissen
wert also wie ich wünsche den wunsch zu
haben
zum beispiel drogen zu nehmen wenn
implizit irgendwie immer schon zu sagen
dass drogen konsumieren eben etwas ist
was sein soll
ok irgendwie sowas er insofern bin ich
nicht ganz sicher aber umgekehrt
natürlich glaube ich jetzt im passage
befreit wurde
es muss nicht immer mehr moralische
genau das ist die frage eben es gibt
auch nicht moralische normativität nur
dass man einfach gewisse ziele etwas gut
findet der welt und auf dieser ebene von
dieser ebene der saal c diese ganz
großen ausrichtungen wie wir die wie wir
unser leben gestalten wollen unsere
maxime vielleicht auch was dafür
wertvoll erachten in dieser welt und da
unterscheiden sich die menschen grund
voneinander grundsätzlich aber kann er
nicht sagen
menschen als menschen personen müssen
immer dieselben koalition zweiter stufe
ausbilden
dann würde die deren individualität
gerade verloren gehen
ich glaube auch hier ist der kern der
individualität verschiedene menschen auf
dieselben willens tendenzen erster stufe
die jetzt nicht immer drogen nehme
drogen nicht nehmen sein müssen es kann
auch schokoladeneis vanilleeis oder noch
andere ganz andere dinge gehe ich jetzt
diesen wunsch nach irgendwie den urlaub
zu gehen oder wie ich diesen wunsch nach
ein buch zu schreiben oder sowas kann
man ganz beliebig in konfliktsituationen
versetzen unterschiedlich darauf
reagieren und das ist also hier scheint
wohl die individualität der person
angelegt sein
natürlich auch letztendlich auf der
ersten stufe weil nicht alle personen
dieselben konstellationen von willens
tendenzen erster stufe in sich vorfinden
was mich zb immer interessiert
vielleicht weißt du dann näheres dazu
woher kommen denn die wildesten erster
stufe wo sind denn die fundiert
offensichtlich doch in unserer natur
auch so ein bisschen natürlich
vielleicht auch in dem kontext also in
unserem geworfen sein die welt würde ich
sagen
die haben wir nicht hintergrund in der
hand was dann uns auftritt zumindest
prima fazit nicht wir können vielleicht
uns auch so konditionieren dass wir die
spannende frage dass tendenziell wünsche
erste stufe einer bestimmten art
auftreten und andere nicht das geht
vielleicht auch sich so zu
konditionieren aber nach diesem modell
ist es so wir finden uns unmittelbar
diese wünsche vor gewisse konstellation
von wünsch erster stufe also ich denke
das hat dann mehrere komponenten basis
hat mehr wurzeln aus der solche position
kommen also sicher die natur und
vielleicht auch nicht in der aber auch
sicher die charakterlinie im lauf der
jahre geformt
so zum beispiel wenn ich ein starkes
verlangen nach einer stresssituation
kann ich vielleicht dafür noch
verantwortung ich sage natürlich in der
vergangenheit so viel geraucht hat das
wunsch kommt auch kommen werden eine
andere der sich immer klar denn nie
geleitet und sich immer klar vor augen
geführt was das führen würde ihm zu
rauchen
der für den kommt es vielleicht nach dem
tragen kommen also dies sind
teilweise dann verantwortlich dass in
bestimmten positionen erster stufe oder
oder vincent wünschen insofern auch so
ein drogenabhängiger natürlich das ist
immer die frage ist ja nicht so als
spannende frage wo jetzt diese wünsche
erster stufe hier wo die fundiert sind
aber nach seinem zum vereinfachten
modell haben wir die einfach in uns wir
finden uns in einer situation situation
1 dass wir verschiedene wünsche gehen
uns spüren die miteinander unter
umständen nicht kompatibel sind und die
uns zu einem problem erst mal werden und
sie werden uns nur insofern zu einem
problem
als wir uns von einer zweiten stufe
darauf beziehen wenn wir uns nicht von
einer zweiten stufe auf wünsche auf
wünsche erster stufe beziehen würden
dann wären wären die für uns auch nicht
problematisch also die tatsache dass wir
das als etwas problematisches ansehen
diese willens situation erster stufe
deutet schon darauf hin dass wir von
einer zweiten stufe aus das ganze
betrachtet das ist glaube ich auch ein
wichtiger punkt ja
das konterspiel
und das genau das ist privat
und irgendwann bin ich dann haben denken
das ist auch möglich dass also aus einer
freien entscheidung heraus man unfrei
wird das ist denke ich auch durchaus
möglich
aber es weiß man eben manchmal nicht
also dass und dann kann man sich wieder
fragen ist unser fehlendes wissen und
selbst auch wieder vorwerfbar das ist
die große frage sind irrtümer sind
irrtümer bloße defekte und rationalen
ausstattung oder sind fehler und
irrtümer nicht doch auch letztendlich
unserer freiheit zu rechnen war unsere
entscheidung das eine ganz spannende
frage die mich grad auch sehr
beschäftigt hat also ein riesenthema
jetzt gehen wir mal noch mal weiter der
andere süchtige ist ein triebhafte wesen
ist dieses beispiel seine handlungen
spiegeln die ökonomie seiner wünsche der
ersten stufe ohne dass es ihn kümmert ob
die wünsche dient zum handeltreiben auch
wünsche sind durch die er sich zum
handeln veranlasst sehen möchte gibt es
probleme an die droge heran zu kommen
oder sie sich zu verabreichen
dann können seine reaktion auf das
verlangen nach der droge verschiedene
überlegungen einschließen
aber es geschieht ihm nie dass er erwägt
oder auch möchte dass sich aus dem
verhältnis seiner wünsche eben der wille
ergibt den er hat der triebhafte
süchtige kann ein tier und deshalb
unfähig sein seinen willen zu bedenken
jedenfalls unterscheidet er sich was
seine triebhafte unbekümmertheit angeht
nicht von einem tier gehen immer noch
mal zurück also dass die person ist
offensichtlich der süchtige wider willen
der hier sich dazu verhält das ist
dieses beispiel der verhält sich zu
seinen wünschen erster stufe
und jetzt gibt es davon noch den
süchtigen als ein triebhafte wesen der
einfach dessen handlungen sozusagen so
aussehen dass sich die stärkere willens
tendenz durchsetzt und diese zweite
stufe hier einfach wegfällt
es gibt also nur verschiedene wünsche
erste stufe nicht zehn nicht zwei- und
das stärkste wie in so einem tauziehen
von wünschen die das stärker wunsch in
dieser situation setzt eben durch das
ist dann so gewesen was er wo er sagen
würde ein
ein mensch der fast schon ein tier sein
könnte das ist natürlich eine durchaus
problematisch ist ja auch noch ob man
nicht doch bereit wäre es selbst
gutmensch und person ist auch nicht
identisch sicherlich ne unter allen
bedingungen nach frankfurt jedenfalls
nicht frankfurt sagte das kleine kinder
keine person sein oder ganz kleine
kinder jedenfalls
das gute ist eine muss man natürlich
sagen wer behauptet jetzt hier nicht
dass ein drogensüchtiger der esel
ökonomie der somit seinen wünschen und
dass deswegen schon keine person ist und
was er machte sie nur einen kleinen
ausschnitt das also unser innenleben ist
ja auch viel leichter als nur es ist ja
denkbar dass dieser drogensüchtige
vielleicht in bezug auf seine wünsche
drogen zu nehmen oder nicht zunehmen in
different ist aber dass selbst
vielleicht auch ganz andere wünsche
leben mehr bei dem er sehr wohl der
position beziehen
sie sagen wir es gesagt das hier nicht
jeder drogensüchtige dieses verhältnis
zu seinen wünschen hat die schönheit für
so sondern dass es im kleinen ausschnitt
gebracht er kann ein tier sein na ja er
könnte also sagte das haben wir auch
eine zusammenfassung haben
ich glaube zu wollen was mit den
personen status auch bestimmte rechte
ein hörgenuss weiter ich glaube dass das
genauso interessiert genau glaube ich
auch er will wirklich nur auf bestimmte
fähigkeiten oder eigenschaften
reflektieren phänomene die ganz
abgegrenzt sind die auch normativ gar
nicht so relevant ist rein deskriptiv
wir verwenden wir den personen begriff
ist am sinnvollsten und zum beispiel
auch so was wie die inter subjektive
dimension die ja auch personalität
auszeichnen sich in kommunikations
verhältnissen zu befinden interessiert
ihn überhaupt nicht
es ist eine rein individualistische
subjektives tische willens objektive
analyse der person
status und ich hätte ihm recht ist dann
werde ich ganz bei ihnen zu sagen das
ist ein fachlich hoch macht zu sagen
dass man nur dann zum beispiel recht auf
leben hatte und recht auf unversehrtheit
wenn man munition zweiter chinesischer
mann angesprochen
das ist natürlich eine these die man
sich gut überlegen sollte wenn man
bedenkt dass man vielleicht aus in der
vase auf dem spiel
hier natürlich auch als kleines kind
leid phasenweise eine phasenweise mensch
am ende des lebens ja zum beispiel auch
im falle von demenz ist die frage ob man
da noch koalition zweiter stufe
ausbilden kann
das wäre problematisch
aber ich glaube nicht dass franck wird
eben nicht so da stimme ich dir zu dass
er das und weitere personen betraten
sehr enger würde ich nur auf bestimmte
fähigkeiten bestimmte akte konzentriert
ok jetzt sagte er folgendes also gut
zusammengefasst ganz kurz wenn eine
person handelt dann leitet sie entweder
der wille den sie haben möchte oder ein
wille den silos sein will wenn einer
triebhaft handelt dann keines von beiden
was also der wille entscheidend ist und
jetzt kommt noch mal was wichtiges nicht
einmal vor wenn ich sage dass es für
personen charakteristisch ist ihre
eigenen wünsche motive wertend zu
beurteilen
also hier kann man durchaus sagen hier
bei cs bisschen bewertung
wer kennt da kommt so eine schwache
normativität ins spiel
so will ich damit nicht unterstellen
dass in den koalitionen zweiter stufe
also hier zehn unbedingt eine moralische
einstellung zum ausdruck kommt die
jemand gegenüber seinen wünschen der
ersten stufe einnimmt
es muss kein moralischer standpunkt
seien von dem aus jemand seine wünsche
der ersten stufe eine beurteilung
unterziehen
bei immanuel kant ist es tendenziell so
dass er sagt koalition zweiter stufe
müssen moralischer natur sein das
sittengesetz und dann bekommen wir dann
das problem der individualität wenn alle
nach denselben positionen zweiter stufe
handeln sollten
das hat dann haben wir keine
individualität mehr richtig wenn das nur
freiheit ist wenn sich die moralität
durchsetzt in die handlung das ist mein
problem was ich da ein bisschen mit
kantaten und deswegen sagte es geht also
nicht um moralität auf dieser zweiten
stufe ist es eine schwache normativität
das können aber auch einfach so
überzeugung sein was meinst du wie man
ein leben gestalten möchte
lebensentwürfen oder was wird sozusagen
was sind kandidaten für rc auf welcher
ebene das diesen weg den ich eben haben
das wäre auch der bahn schwer ist denke
ich immer dass kann mir völlig egal und
genau das habe ich vielleicht das eben
und das wäre trotzdem munition zweiter
stufe in diesen aber aber was mich jetzt
interessiert in welcher auf welcher
ebene
es ist diese ist diese position zweiter
stufe angesiedelt also das müssen ja
sehr grundsätzlichen überzeugungen
betreffen oder es müssen wohl grund
grundüberzeugung sein oder was meinst
ich denke man könnte das modell dann
noch ein bisschen erhalten indem man in
dessen ja auch koalition geben also auch
da sieht man's akt die will sagte können
natürlich schon durch bestimmte
überzeugungen die auch moralischen tun
sein können
wir können es noch nicht darüber sagte
er nichts und es scheint nicht mehr
aufschlagen
das land rover das ist ein problem genau
aber eine möglichkeit ist nie verlegen
überzeugungen dass der wunsch drogen zu
nehmen
und deswegen will ich eine position
jedenfalls kommt die vernunft auch ein
bisschen spielen also das deutet er an
dass er seine vernunft können wir die
position zweiter stelle die
ausbildungszeit erscheint schon
irgendwie zumindest versteckt also
anzudeuten dass diese positionen
vielleicht aus vernünftige über bierun
kommen aus vernünftige bewegung zumkehr
bestimmt
genau zum beispiel sagt also ich muss
deswegen jetzt nicht entscheiden weil
wenn ich es nicht täte dann würde in
fünf jahren das passieren zum beispiel
sich mögliche fälle konstruiert was wäre
denn wenn ich jetzt annahme in dieser
situation dann würde das dazu führen und
das wäre auf lange frist für mich nicht
günstig so eine instrumentelle
überlegung wäre vielleicht auch anders
eine 1 10 polizei
es muss dann gleich moralisch die
starken seiten irgendwie so wie im
chaotischen sittengesetz und vielleicht
sagt er es aber natürlich klarer tief
leicht zum problem aus so stichwort hall
und tourismus intellektualismus also wie
ich diese debatte stehe
die hat natürlich viele facetten eine
frage ist wenn ich durch vernünftige
überlegungen zur überzeugung gelangt
dass eine bestimmte handlungsoptionen
die beste ist unter vielen verschiedenen
kann ich dann überhaupt noch anders
wollen als die vernünftige überlegungen
vorliegt oder nicht das ist so eine
frage und dann würden die in präfektur
listen tendenziell eher sagen nein die
wohnung touristen schon ich dann will
man quelle kann sich emanzipiert um eine
vernünftige bewegung
wir haben das jetzt nicht zu aktionen
genommen
also ich kann anders wollen als mir
meine vernünftige überzeugung vor dass
würde er bestimmt so es ist so ein
problem ist eher ausgewanderten frage
stellen woher kommen die position zeit
der stufen sind die entstanden wie
entstehen genügen kommen die einfach so
aus dem nichts in die einen können
können nämlich genauso über kommen
der erste stufe oder müssen wie gebildet
vielleicht in einem vernünftigen
abwägung genau das wird dann der lebara
tief sind die liberati verständnis
[Musik]
wer ein preis bestimmen
die hängt es dann zusammen mit jetzt
einen möglichen freien willen oder ist
drei habe ich über das tor
also ohne stress zu kontrastieren ist
für frankfurt werden darf wichtig ist
nur dass position zweiter stufe im
einklang mit den wünschen vieler wenig
sagen da muss ich die personen ein
klasse
woher die division heimischen vögeln ist
freiheit hätten
das sind natürlich problematisch
zusammengesetzt dass manche regionen
deswegen ein reger trinken die frage ist
zum beispiel wenn es auf seine intuition
herkommt diese position 20 schulen sind
bewährte wünschen können wir dann
möglich noch in freiheit sprechen muss
es eine rationale prozess sein steckt
die freien flächen eine
internationalität sie von den nationalen
eingesehen irgendwie auch emanzipieren
also da ist die ganz große debatten die
geschichte philosophie durchzieht wie
hier natürlich jetzt nicht nicht so
gefordert
[Musik]
diese einsetzen
vielleicht wäre es auch besser statt von
vernunft zu sprechen oder von
rationalität von gründen zu sprechen und
zwei gründe sind nie rein rationale
entitäten sondern gründe sind immer wie
mir scheint verwobenheit von willens
tendenzen und rationalität also ich
glaube dass man bei den vernunft und
wille nicht nicht voneinander separieren
kann das ist eine abstraktion meinen
augen
sie liegen immer in einer fusionierung
vor also gründe sind sofern sie uns
motivieren können immer willentlich
strukturierte rationalität selektive
rationalität deswegen glaube ich hat
frankfurt dieses problem von wohl und
tourismus und ra und intellektualismus
nicht weil er sagt sie gibt es nur in
kombination in vereinigungen
verschiedene gewichtung verschiedene
richtungen vielleicht zu können all das
wäre so als ich glaube man kann es
auflösen und jemand von gründen spricht
zum beispiel macht das handy darüber
liegen professor nida rümelin der auch
ein vortrag auf dieser tagung halten
wird wofür sie sich hier anmelden können
der wird dann sagen wir sind deswegen
frei trotz aller naturgesetze weil wir
gründe
bis jetzt seien gründe lassen sich nicht
naturalisten gründe lassen sich nicht
naturalistisch beschreiben das ist sein
argument kann man gründe naturalis ihren
natürlich kann man sich fragen gibt es
überhaupt gründe
was sind gründe riesenthema aber damit
könnte man vielleicht auch diesem
problem so ein bisschen nachhelfen
so ist es
so gesteht es gerade wenn es ein problem
weil wir dazu neigen
wer in der sprache nominierung genau
jener und dann sprechen wir von der
vernunft die wieder steigern die
empfehlen und dann gibt es noch die
wünsche da unten und dann haben wir
einen haufen von entitäten wir
postulieren und hier fängt alle kräfte
falten sind ein bisschen natürlich in
der folge lassen was war es gibt eine
person und die kann bestehen will
bestimmte dinge die tut bestimmt wird
das aber immer schon getan schon bei
platon wenn sie vielleicht sich ein
bisschen mit der polit er mit seiner
schrift der staat beschäftigt haben er
spricht von drei sälen teilen da fängt
das an und da gibt es eben den höchsten
seelen teil des logistik und den
vernünftigen sie internet gibt es den
mittleren dass es der mut hafte und da
gibt es null unterstes der triebhafte
und die müssen sich gegenseitig
kontrollieren also der oberste sollte
untersten in schach halten
da fängt schon an solche solche modelle
was eine frage noch ist die mich
interessiert dann gehen wir weiter ist
das kann auch in die diskussion jetzt
geben oder für später ist nicht das
schon dass ich also eine koalition
zweiter stufe dass die gebilde wird in
dem partei ergriffen wird von a und b
ist das nicht eigentlich auch schon eine
handlung also mich mich interessiert die
frage gibt es innere handlungen oder
gibt es nur äußere handlung wo ich dann
aktiv was tue als irgendwie einen stift
nehmen oder mich in diese richtung
bewegen gibt es innere handlungen das
ist die frage
und das führt jetzt zu einem weiteren
punkt nämlich diesem regress problem
dann möchte ich auch noch ganz kurz zu
sprechen kommen also dass auch noch mal
ganz kurz dazwischen nur weil eine
person koalition der zweiten stufe hat
kann sie sich der freiheit ihres willens
erfreuen oder auch ihrer r mangeln
der begriff der person ist also nicht
nur der begriff eines wesens das sowohl
wünsche erster stufe wie auch koalition
zweiter stufe hat sondern lässt sich
auch als begriff eine art von wesen fas
und verdient die freiheit ihres willens
ein problem sein kann das finde ich sehr
gute beschreibung dieser betrieb
schließt alle triebhaften wesen ob
mensch oder tier aus denn sie erfüllen
eine wesentliche bedingung um willens
wald genießen zu können nicht und
erschließt wenn es sie gibt alle
übermenschlichen wesen aus deren willen
notwendig frei ist auch eine
interessante sache dass ich hier mal
schaut müssen auch mal so ein bisschen
über uns hinaus schauen also zb engel
oder sowas haben engel notwendigerweise
freien frei wählen
wahrscheinlich denkt der ein engel denke
ich jetzt meine oder vielleicht auch
besondere außerirdische ja weil er eben
van wees entspricht aber alle erst mal
engel engel nahe oder so was gibt es in
der mittelalterlichen debatte viele
diskussionen darüber wie es mit engeln
und so aussieht aber was ich noch einmal
hervorheben wollte ist hier also dass
die freiheit des willens ein problem
sein kann
das ist
dass man beim ersten lesen des aufsatzes
könnte man meinen dass er eigentlich
dahin würden zusagen zur person sei es
nicht leicht wird vernünftig sein
sondern es gleich wird mit den zwei
seiten
und es ist ja nicht so sondern er sagt
die person ist etwas für die 70 eigene
winds freiheit ein problem sein leben
das es wert wenn es weiter freuen oder
jene auch am markt
also will zwar jetzt endlich los wenn
man das einmal in person so sagt genau
das beispiel ersten tag der
koalitionsverhandlungen an seinen
wünschen verzeihen aber letztlich person
bei der weiler verzweifelt
er verhält sich einfach zu sich selbst
in dieser beziehung auf polizei willens
tendenzen erster stufe das heißt er hat
diese koalition zweiter stufe gebildet
auch wenn sie ihm das muss man eben dazu
sagen nach der definition dann eben
nicht handlungs wirksam wären definierte
einige koalition zweiter stufe auch als
handlungs wirksame
[Musik]
also ich glaube ich die position selten
wunsch sein und es muss also nicht
unbedingt in der handlung okay dass der
handlungs wirksam ist auch wenn dann
natürlich diese koalition am ende nicht
handlungs wirksam werden könnte in
letzter konsequenz ja genau also man
könnte sagen sagen was eine person für
frankfurt ausmacht ist einfach ein
selbst verhältnis zweiter stufe zu sich
herzustellen das nicht in different ist
und gewisse tendenzen bewährten ins
spiel kommen und selbst wenn es nichts
und handlung führt sind wir dann noch
eine person nicht will zwar aber eben
die person das ist das leuchtet mir ein
ja genau dann weiteres zitat was wichtig
ist wenn wir fragen auch eine person ein
frieden freien willen hat dann fragen
nicht danach ob sie in der lage ist das
ist der punkt ihre wünsche erster stufe
in die tat umzusetzen das wäre die frage
ob sie frei ist zu tun was ihr gefällt
die frage nach der willensfreiheit
betrifft nicht das verhältnis zwischen
dem was jemand tut und dem was er tun
möchte
sind sie betrifft die wünsche selber
also das ist gar nicht so sehr dass
diese handlung jetzt so ins zentrum
gestellt wird es ist ihr so dieser
willentliche prozess der hier eine rolle
spielt ein sehr komplexes wesentliches
verhältnis
und das ist noch mal hier eine schöne
beschreibung dessen was was
willensfreiheit ist und was
handlungsfreiheit ist und hier noch
einmal ganz kurz ist ist ihm wichtig
dass er diese frage des willens
verhalten was handlungsfreiheit sind
genauer analogie konstruiert was
handlungsfreiheit ist also
handlungsfreiheit tun zu können was man
möchte was man will und willensfreiheit
bedeutet dass man frei ist zu wollen was
man wollen möchte in diesem fall also in
diesem sinne ist der verzweiflung
richtige nicht willst dass dieser der
wunsch der linken hand und wirksam wird
das ist ein bitte ist aber dass dieser
dieser wille von ihm sofern es rechtlich
weil da gibt es eben zwischen erster und
zweiter ja wobei man durchaus auch sagen
könnte man kann ja auch willens frei
sein wenn es nicht zu einer handlung
führt also willensfreiheit ist ja nur
was war es zwischen diesen zwei stufen
stattfindet oder
[Musik]
jedenfalls sehen uns ja einig um willens
frei zu sein muss sich nicht am ende zur
behandlung kommen
das ist weil er sagt ja auch einer
anderen stelle ich bin dann perfekt frei
wenn ich mein wunsch bestimmen kann
und wenn das auch noch handlungs wirksam
wird
das ist dann so die die perfekte freitag
schon mal kurz das ist nochmal ein
wichtiges zitat jemand macht also dann
von seiner willensfreiheit gebraucht
wenn es sicherstellt dass sein wille und
seine volition zweiter stufe bei 1
stimmen das ist auch nur also dass wir
so ein harmonie modell das auch ganz
wichtig ist das war ein zitat wo er sagt
wenn man beides hat als seinen willen
bestimmen kann und dann noch handlungs
frei ist dann ist man perfekt dann
braucht man nicht mehr zu wollen
erinnerst du dich an die passage
[Musik]
das will er nicht sagen
und dann wäre es wieder und dann wäre es
wieder so dass dann doch willensfreiheit
stärker zur person gehören würde dann
geld
12 personen die gerade so aus china hat
mehr so ist
wir trennen stark solchen personen tätig
sein und sagen sollen und auch angegeben
damit keine linsmaier fragen weil wir
uns eine kompliziert ist dass der wunsch
ins amt wählen bitte ist das anderes
gemacht
es war ein echter prävention wie ich
irgendwo eine planung die anderen auch
la galaxy tab ist dass man sagt man will
uns handlungsfreiheit muss man auch
stand ein mann deswegen genau geht nicht
die tagungs wirksamkeit an einher und
deswegen ist diese das müssen wir mal so
offen lassen könnte man zb auch sehr
schöne hausarbeit mal behandeln also was
ist jetzt eigentlich die person ist sie
willens frei ist willensfreiheit für ihn
etwas was dann so eine handlung führt
oder ist willensfreiheit nur etwas das
ich dass ich erfolgreich dass irgendwas
heißt erfolgreich schon die frage der
erfolgreichen partei ergreifen kann
etwas auch wenn es dann nichts mehr
handlung führt vielleicht das ist
[Musik]
aber es ist jedenfalls ist es mir auch
nicht so bewusst gewesen genau jetzt
kommt noch mal hier
dieses ganz bekannte regress probleme
dann wollen wir aber auch zum nächsten
sex über gehen weil das in der letzten
sitzung auch noch kurz angeklungen ist
also sehr schwierig wird die lage auch
dadurch dass eine person besonders dann
wenn unter ihren wünschen der zweiten
stufe ein widerstreit besteht also
wünscht der zweiten stufe ein
widerstreit besteht wünsche und
koalition noch dass sie noch höherer
stufe wünschen koalition haben kann
theoretisch gibt es kein ende in der
langen reihe von wünschen hörer und
immer höherer stufe nichts außer einem
geraden verstand und vielleicht einer
rettenden ermüdung hindert jemanden wie
besessen die identifikation mit einem
seiner wünsche zu vermeiden ehe er sich
nicht ein wunsch der nächst höheren
stufe gebildet hat die tendenz sich in
einer solchen drei von wunsch bildungs
akten also immer höher zu verlieren die
dann ein fall von wildgewordenen
menschlich reflektierendem bewusstsein
wäre führt auch zur zerstörung der
person also wer sagt denn dass wir hier
schon gleich volition zweiter stufe
haben könnte nicht dass auch nur ein
wunsch zweiter stufe sein der mit einem
anderen wunsch zweiter stufe zb de auch
in ähnlichen widerstreit wie die wünsche
erster stufe und so weiter dann kann man
sagen dann haben wir hier
ich habe mal die zweite tafel zu helfen
die gibt es nicht die gibt es gar nicht
also müssen sich hier denken und dann
könnte man sagen wie der f und g h i und
so weiter und so fort
und wo ist da das ende und jetzt das ist
dieses regress problem das ist ein
riesenproblem das klingt jetzt ein
bisschen konstruiert aber warum denn
nicht warum muss denn hier schon
bitteschön diese das ende eher langsam
jetzt hatte dazu eine interessante these
dass ich auch noch mal kurz vor
er sagt es ist aber möglich eine solche
reihe abzuschließen ohne sie willkürlich
abzuschließen und abzuschneiden und
willkürlich wäre jetzt ein negativer
begriff von willkür einfach ich höre
einfach mal auf ich bin jetzt müde und
jetzt nehme ich diese koalition c weil
sie die letzte ist die ich mir dass
dieser wunsch zweite stufe die nehme ich
jetzt der soll die koalition sein weil
jetzt habe ich keine lust mehr so oder
ich warte jetzt noch fünf minuten genau
fünf minuten und die letzte der letzte
wunsch zweiter stufe oder welcher stufe
auch immer endstufe der da eintritt der
soll meine position sein da soll man
will es sein so das wäre willkürlich und
dann sagt er das darf natürlich nicht
sein wir müssen schon gründe oder wir
müssen schon die entscheidung auf eine
begründete weise vollziehen wenn sich
eine person entschlossen mit einem ihrer
wünsche der ersten stufe identifiziert
dann durch halt diese bindung dem ganzen
potenziell endlosen raum höhere stufen
betrachten wir eine person die
rückhaltlos und ohne zwiespalt von dem
wunsch sich auf ihre arbeit zu
konzentrieren
motiviert sein möchte dass ihre
koalition zweiter stufe von diesem
wunsch bewegt werden entschlossen ist
weg zu werden entschlossen ist heißt
dass kein raum für die frage ist ob
wünsche oder volition höherer stufe
irgend von belang sind
neben die an der betreffende werde
gefragt ob er den wunsch zu haben möchte
dass er sich wünsche sich auf seine
arbeit zu konzentrieren dann könnt ihr
ganz richtig darauf bestehen dass ich
diese frage nach einem wunsch dritter
stufe nicht der hebel
es wäre falsch zu behaupten dass er
deshalb weil er sich nicht die frage
vorgelegt hat ob er seine volition
zweiter stufe haben möchte
nur unentschieden gegenüber der frage
wäre ob er möchte dass sein wille mit
dieser koalition zweiter stufe oder
einer anderen übereinstimmung
die entschiedenheit seines entschlusses
bedeutet zugleich die entscheidung dass
ich in bezug auf seine volition zweiter
stufe keine fragen irgend einer höheren
ordnung stellen
es hängt nicht viel davon ab ob wir
diesen sachverhalten nur dadurch
erklären dass wir sagen die entschluss
erzeugt implizit eine endlose reihe
einstimmiger wünsche höhere stufe oder
dass wir sagen der entschluss löse alle
fragen höherer stufe dadurch auf dass er
ihnen den ansatzpunkt entzieht das
vielleicht noch ganz kurz zu abschluss
dieses textes war wie jetzt dann auch
übergehen müssen was ist jetzt das
argument warum sagt frankfurt stellt
sich diese frage jetzt gar nicht ob wir
jetzt hier noch gfgh usw haben warum
sagte können wir aus welchen gründen mit
welchen argumenten können wir dieses
diesen regress vermeiden diese
unendliche reihe die wie er sagt die
person zerstören würde
was ist das entscheidende was bedeutet
anders gefragt tee zu setzen was
bedeutet es mit blick auf alle möglichen
höheren positionen oder wünschen
das ist hier im text auch enthalten
das ist hier dieser satz
auch zum beispiel
und das ist auch so ein punkt
haben sie eine idee wie kann man das
jetzt begründen warum kann man sagen ist
mit einer zweiten stufe eigentlich jede
weitere stufe warum könnte mit einer
zweiten stufe jede potenziell höhere
stufe eigentlich schon passiert sein
ja ist die meldung
das ist ja schon erlebt ihn brauchten
glücklich wenn ich dann ins bett
ich denke es geht in die richtige
richtung als der punkt ist der marco du
korrigiert mich sagt also richtig mit
dieser die reflexion reicht schon aus um
alle weiteren instanzen einzuschließen
also mit dieser zweiten stufe hat mich
eigentlich schon alle zukünftigen stufen
reflektiert die sind ja schon
eingeschlossen
bzw diese potenziellen anderen konflikt
wünsche die gehen eigentlich schon in
die zweite stufe mit 1 könnte man sagen
also die die muss ich schon irgendwie
antizipieren so ein bisschen jedenfalls
oder ich entschieden mich zumindest wenn
ich zum ausbilden dass es nicht mehr
geben wird das scheint damit impliziert
zu sein auf eine gewisse weise hätten
sie das auch so
ja könnte man vielleicht auch sagen dass
also jedenfalls das irgendwie und man
kann es auch so sagen das einfach die
erste stufe um die zweite stufe
kategorischen anderer natur sind
dass man also die nicht analog behandeln
darf einfach wie so eine nummer sind
dass das einfach das entscheidend ist
und dass damit eigentlich alles weitere
hier eingeschlossen ist dass man das
nicht falsch verstehen darf sondern dass
der entscheidende einfach der von zwei
zu eins ist und dass damit dann schon
getan
letztendlich marco was hast du noch eine
idee dazu
soll ich jetzt ob das wirklich ein
problem ist die die position recht genau
so wenig sein dürfte sind wir auch
verstehen dass mit immer bewusst sein
wir müssen uns sagen wir nur dann
position zweiter stufe wenn wir uns
jetzt auch zum bus wenn er darauf ja
antwortet dann werden sie doch sehr
problematische weise während hängen mich
nicht zugänglich sind fast nie im leben
bewusst population zweiten stunde aus
bitte also normalerweise wenn ich mir
überlege was ich tun würde würde ich was
ich tun soll also sollte ich jetzt nach
hause gehen oder noch eine stunde
arbeiten soll diese hausarbeiten und
spanien also normalerweise wenn wir den
übertragen wir uns welche angebote es
gewusst eigentlich fast nie welche
wünsche mir dass ich das ist schon sehr
so manche sagen auch so ein bisschen
polemisch gefragt wird das ist eine sehr
realistische sicht eine sehr
realistische handlungs theorie keine
menschen mehr so darauf bedacht ist was
da für wirtschaft also ich denke kein
für das gut beraten zu sagen positionen
müssen sich immer bewusst sein sondern
ist es mehr was wir positionieren weil
wir eben bestimmtes verhalten erklären
es muss nicht unbedingt bewusst sein und
dann natürlich die entscheidende frage
also wenn es kein zurück geben würde
na gut aber wenn du dir anfangen so was
die post wieder
es muss nicht unbedingt bewusst sagt
natürlich längst hat sie schon mal in
frage gestellt ob er den wunsch haben
wir den wunsch zugunsten irgendeiner
natürlich muss auch da hat es erlag aber
wenn er sagt opposition müssen dann ist
es schwieriger man dann zu beginn die
frage nah warum soll und wenn ich eine
unendliche reihe von koalitionen
probieren und dann bin ich mir nicht so
ganz überzeugt sagen das ist ein
kategorialen unterschied ist es ist ist
es vielleicht auch noch hier so dieser
punkt dieser metapher des durchhaltens
und hier entschlossen diese
entschlossenheit
das hat das von verbindlichkeiten auch
ein riesen begriff verbindlichkeiten und
frankfurt bringt dann auch noch in einem
anderen werk solche modi der
verbindlichkeiten spiel zum beispiel
liebe ist für insassen sondern eben eine
position zwei stufen
das ist einfach die verbindlichkeiten da
haben auch ein stark emotionalen gehalt
drin oder an die reflexion auch gerade
mal so stark ist caring und so solche
sachen fürsorge sorge aber auch ein
schönes thema von der hausarbeit denke
ich ohne jetzt ins letzte detail
man könnte auch sagen egal welche
weitere stufe des dann ist der könnte
man sagen fast willkürlich s -reihe ist
einfach wie das es dass andy stufe
größer gleich zwei ist einfach damit
alles erfüllt ist das kant ist dann egal
ob es jetzt fünfte stufe der zehnte
stufe ist ist einfach größer gleich zwei
und nicht mehr auf der ersten stufe
alles was größer als eins ist erfüllt
dann die brücke mögliche bedingung für
willensfreiheit ja sogar das ist das ist
es ist ich meine das spricht ja
metaphorisch nur wenig hallen und dies
ist eine person entschlossen und
identifiziert was ist denn
entschlossenheit anderes als willkür
also jetzt halt mal so gut also
spannendes thema ich glaube wir gehen
jetzt gar nicht mehr weiter auf diese
anderen er sagt hier eben nach unten
manche haben ist leicht hier den genuss
der freiheit zu kommen andere müssen
kämpfen um sie zu erlangen
aber das scheint doch auch personal zu
sein also spannende frage und
genau jetzt ist noch mal das ist noch
ein schönes abschluss zitat jemand der
frei ist zu tun was er möchte braucht
darum noch nicht in der lage zu sein den
willen zu haben den er haben möchte
das ist ja handlungsfreiheit aber nehmen
wir an dass er beides genießt handlungs
und willensfreiheit dann ist er nicht
allein zur frei nicht allein frei zu tun
was er möchte
das wäre handlungsfreiheit sondern er
ist auch frei zu wollen was wir wollen
möchte und das wäre willensfreiheit nach
dieser ach so super hier sagt er
umgekehrt also man kann auf alle fälle
haben wildenstein und wenn man beides
hat empfehlen sagen freiheitlich sehr
interessante frage warum zu entscheiden
welche der beiden interpretation von 537
das ist viel kann man auch wilson und
deshalb eine interessante frage da muss
man sich genau anschauen
die definierten entweder definierter
wunsch und wie also welche worte
benutzte einen englischen text bei mir
das schon so ein bisschen danach klingt
handlungsfeld und willensfreiheit dass
es so komplementär ist so ein bisschen
dass das also für sich genommen noch
nicht irgendwie also richtig ausreicht
dass die hand
das aber ist ein gutes thema von dem aus
ich habe es ein bisschen strenger
gelesen genau also das ist glaube ich
schon dass abschluss die tat und jetzt
mal guckt jetzt gehen wir schnell über
zungen letzten text die folien stellen
wir als auch noch ins internet und hier
ist jetzt ein folgender text relevant
und den haben wir sogar auch noch auf
deutsch auftreiben können als sie werden
jetzt hier an der wand deutsche zitate
finden und das ist jetzt also der
aufsatz übersetzt alternative
handlungsmöglichkeiten und moralische
verantwortung auch hier haben wir wieder
ein paar fragen wie lautet das prinzip
der alternativen möglichkeiten das kürzt
man auch mit php ab werden sie immer mal
wieder finden
php weitere frage ist warum ist das
prinzip der alternativen möglichkeiten
plausibel
zumindest auf den ersten blick kann man
sich situationen überlegen den jemand
versagen handeln nicht moralisch
verantwortlich ist weil er nicht anders
handeln konnte warum glaubt frank führt
dass dieses prinzip ungültig ist er sagt
sogar es ist falsch
und wie lautet das prinzip dass
frankfurt vorschlägt um das prinzip der
alternativen möglichkeiten zu ersetzen
jetzt haben wir das zum glück noch auf
deutsch gefunden wir schicken den text
auch noch herum
der ist aus dieser text sammlung
entnommen den frau professor die frau
professor bezler herausgegeben hat ich
lese einfach mal vor praktisch niemand
scheint geneigt die wahrheit des auf die
eine oder andere art verstanden prinzips
alternative handlungsmöglichkeiten zu
bestreiten oder gar zu hinterfragen es
erweckt allgemein den anschein eines zu
über w einer zur überwältigenden
plausibilität dass einige philosophen
ist sogar als eine apriori wahrheit
charakterisiert haben menschen die sich
in ihren den freien willen und die
moralische verantwortlichkeit
betreffenden darstellung im
grundsätzlichen szene uneins sind finden
offensichtlich in ihm einen festen und
die ähnlichen grund auf dem sie
gemeinsam auf einträgliche weise
gegeneinander stellung beziehen können
also primär fazit können uns sagen dass
php ist gehört zum konsens das gehört
zur grundausstattung mann würde sagen
das ist irgendwie auf jeden fall
notwendig und vielleicht sogar
hinreichend für willensfreiheit wenn ich
alternative möglichkeiten habe real das
notwendig muss zumindest sagen ich muss
alternative möglichkeit schon mal haben
ja notwendig
zugleich genießen deshalb fremd wird in
diesen ausgemacht 29 10 69 ganz genau
wie er hat genau
und da haben wir neue was sagen
eigentlich das geben alle vertreter zu
der heutigen schwarzer auf die gegner
und vielleicht geben zu dass dieser
aufsatz ganz auf seine neue platte zu
studieren und da geht es darum dass sich
jetzt alle einfach dieses prinzip macht
aus dem nix habe zwar das prinzip wenn
ich moralische verantwortung für meine
hand und verständlich auch anders kommen
kann
das ist uns eben alternative
möglichkeiten und ist jetzt noch
vorausgesetzt und deswegen haben alle
hier zu machen
in frage gestellt während der minister
ist wenn die physik uns an die flüssig
herausfindet dass hier dass man die welt
in die touristischen und judith stube
steigen kann können wir dann noch
anderes handelt oder nicht das ist die
frage debattiert und um alle
vorausgesetzt pinsel die basis wenn man
nicht anders sagen kann dass man
das heißt wenn unsere länderminister
niemand moral
das war und deswegen natürlich ist mir
natürlich weitere konsequenzen unseres
selbst und was fremd für diesen kleinen
aufsatz macht was man natürlich auf den
ersten blick ist er leitet eine ganz
neue argumentation möglichkeit angesehen
sagte nämlich das was dann später andere
aufgegriffen haben zum beispiel schon
macht und fischer die nehmen das wort zu
sagen aha man kann über alles
verantwortlich seien auch nicht anders
nennen ist es auf die frage ob er anders
handeln können wir nicht anders handeln
können
die innenminister nicht in die feinde
sondern die moralische verantwortung
das können wir vielleicht auf einen
veganen anders handeln können das ist
der zeitpunkt also verein wird hiermit
ganz neue richtungen ganz neue der
philosophischen position bis heute ein
guter punkt da das darauf hinweist
da verschiebt sich jetzt ja auch soll
der schwerpunkt von der frage nach
willensfreiheit er nicht zum moralischen
verantwortung
häufig setzen wir das auch in einzeln
sack zu also willens frei bedeutet dass
es notwendig dafür und dann deswegen bin
ich moralisch zurechenbar und dass man
das auch mal voneinander unterscheiden
und sagt das muss nicht auseinander
früheren
der erste dieser aus verschieden ist
haben alle genauso gedacht
also wir debattieren überwindet warum
naja was uns einig dass sie das
natürlich male stand und wir wollen
wissen ob jemand der brutal ermordet hat
und der für moralisch verantwortlich ist
oder nicht hin aber wie es debattieren
verwendet warum weil wir nicht in zwei
jahren waren also wenn er keine große
preis wird die zeit ist nicht alles
erlauben können oder es versucht zu
sagen das ist eine ganz neue verändertes
liquent ob das heute deswegen wird die
debatte heute konzentriert sie zum
großen teil auf die frage sind die moral
schwanken und es war da schon nicht so
report hauptsächlich über die frage
debattiert über alternative
möglichkeiten
man hat schon sagen dass es tatsächlich
mehr verschiedenen gegeben hat jetzt
über tippmann hauptsächlich über sprache
es gibt natürlich immer die ausnahme es
gibt einen behäbigen die getränke
mitgehen
die weiterbildungsreihe über tieren aber
den großen zeiten über den letzten
moralischen verantwortung gehen wir mal
weiter aber das prinzip alternative
möglichkeiten ist falsch eine person
kann wohl für ihr team moralische
verantwortung tragen
obwohl sie nicht anders hätte handeln
können die plausibilität des prinzips
ist eine illusion
die dadurch zum verschwinden gebracht
werden kann dass man die relevanten
moralischen phänomene genauer betrachtet
und das möchte jetzt machen und zwar
eben anhand von beispielen
fallbeispielen das ist ja auch ein
typischer vorteil von frankfurts
philosophie dass er wie sie auch schon
bei diesem ersten aufsatz gesehen hatten
immer verschiedene gedanken beispiele
konstruiert wie im falle eines
drogensüchtigen sagt er kann man zwei
verschiedene fälle voneinander
unterscheiden und die sind sehr relevant
für die fragen nach den 2
statt mit ihr so ein bisschen weil er
auf der ersten blick klingt ist total
verrückt gemacht also wenn ich jemanden
umgebracht habe und aber nicht alles
nichts anderes machen als ich und ich
vielleicht irgendwann zuschlag
vielleicht weil ich dazu gezwungen
problem umzubringen oder nehmen wir an
rich content anders als diese menschen
umzubringen bescheinigung ist endlich zu
sagen das sind dann mit moralischer
dafür bilden das nicht und ist aber
dagegen beschlossen für die
funktionieren im prinzip wie folgendes
beispiel im 14
vom prinzip sind heißt es scherzhaft
wenn ein student sehr aufgeweckt wird
vom bäcker und ich muss eine wichtige
vorlesung besuchen
und wie immer an das sich aus reiner
faulheit beschließe diese ohne mich zu
diesen vorlesungen nicht zu diesen
natürlich in ihrem song my ride plätzen
bleiben einfach umzudrehen weiter zu
schlafen sony stellt das man vor dass
das natürlich ein schlag von längst
wieder dass es eine lesung verkehrschaos
in münchen
alle waren empfanden aus den ganzen
verkehr so lagen die leichen
das heißt wenn wir uns vor ich hätte
vorher buchen können wenn ich es
versucht hätte dann welche gescheitert
war ist ein riesen verkehrschaos klar
also was wir jetzt mehr ein beispiel
durch etwas getan habe nämlich ein
präsent zu sein ich lasse mich besucht
ich hatte allerdings anders zu können
falls sie nicht zu bekommen ich hätte
gar nicht anders sagen können man ist
versucht hätte dann würde ich
gescheitert was diesen verkehrsausgaben
und sonstigen sagen hat ist aus reiner
form also diese studenten trotzdem
moralisch verantwortlich
also erinnerte es auch dann gemacht wenn
die bahn über wenn sie das verkehrshaus
nicht gegeben hätte wenn er die
vorlesung besuchen
sie trotzen deswegen scheint wenn jetzt
wenn jetzt wer professor diesen
studenten zur rede gestellt und
zuwanderung sind sie da nicht erschienen
zu mit räumlicher und er dann sagt er
ich komme gar das gas im verkehrshaus
würde sagen das ist doch kanal erreicht
die von einer faust also bestimmt ist
wahr was er sagt er hätte die
vollziehung gar nicht besuchen können
aber wenn er sie hätte besuchen können
dann hätte es in deutschland besucht
also wahrscheinlich eine parade ist ein
paradefall von faule ausrede zu sagen
statt echter entschulden und das sind
also das ist so wie gewohnt die lösung
ein
es gibt fälle in denen wir etwas also
sowieso tun würden egal ob es anders
hätte handeln können oder nicht und in
diesen fällen sind wir auf die moralisch
verantwortlich
nun können warum weil wir anders hätten
haben können und hätten trotzdem genauso
mehr an nützlichen das ist die grund und
bei meisten hintergrund hat haben
versteht man warum dieses prinzip wo es
auf den ersten blick plausibel ist
letztlich vielleicht nicht differenziert
gegen das mit unterschiedlichen
zwischenfällen wo jemand sowieso aus
eigenem antrieb
diese schlechte andere geht hier ihr
begangen hat oder sie nur deswegen
begriff weil es gut ja ich denke das ist
hast du recht klar dargestellt und jetzt
gehen wir mal auf den text da ist eine
meldung ja
die schwestern den man verstehe ich
nämlich wenn jetzt also
eigentlich schon zurück und ordentlich
weil ich so geladen haben nichts getan
und es ist ja
welchen zu sprechen
er hat das sind wir also wenn geld
reicht hier vom moralisches anderem
später muss man das moralisch geboten
es gibt hier nicht um rechtliche
verhandlungen ist das natürlich sehr weh
getan oder sondern es geht um eine
moralische bewertung der entscheidung
dieser versuche also ein barbarisches
ist gut oder böse dass die unabhängig
davon ob das jetzt auf das recht nicht
in die band ist zur verantwortung ziehen
könnte schnell ist kann man schon
wichtig dass man es da trennt als sonst
ist die sache ganz anders
das ist für die frage wird also wie also
wie moralisch bewerten da also die frage
ob wir in der chemischen lage sind
herauszufinden was wirklich sache ist
moralisch bildung das ist irrelevant in
frage wie passt das war eine schlimme
sache
es kann sein dass wir das nie
herausfinden können dass er das nur aus
eigenem antrieb hat und trotzdem hat das
nur aus einem mann und deswegen ist er
woanders schlecht auch wenn sie
vielleicht moralisch und halten weil er
uns in selten sehr gut aussehen aber ein
wichtiger posten
selbst
auch in argentinien ja aber genau der
reise zum beispiel das verkehrshaus war
genau und wenn ja wie man einfach mal
weiter
zur veranschaulichung des prinzips
alternative handlungsmöglichkeiten
das muss heißen liegt liegt es am
nächsten sich situation vorzustellen
welche dieselben umstände sowohl
bewirken dass eine person irgendetwas
tut als ob es ihr unmöglich machen
dieses tun zu verhindern
zu solchen situationen gehören zum
beispiel jeden welchen eine person
irgendetwas zu tun gezwungen und durch
hypnotische suggestion zum handeln
gedrängt wird oder in welchen irgend ein
innerer zwang sie das zutun treibt was
sie tut in situationen dieser art machen
dass die umstände der person unmöglich
anders zu handeln und genau diese
umstände die in dem zweck dass sie das
tut was sie tun worum es sich dabei auch
immer handeln mag quasi das beispiel des
verkehrs chaos gebracht
wenn wir sagen und ich habe ich habe
einfach unwiderstehlich wie vor auf dem
wasser und trinkt ein kind und ich kann
dieses kind immer mit den vorwurf machen
dass sich das kind dabei helfen sollen
das eigentlich hätte es gar nicht retten
können weil ich probiere university
unten in diesem fall eines scheint diese
entschuldigung ganz ok zu sein warum
weil das gelte was ihn daran hindert
element nur noch das ist was mich dazu
bringt zu tun was ist aber dass diese
anderen religiösen studenten erzählt
alles ist so sich selber aus einem
überlegung ist so eine art von über
determination könnte man das nicht sagen
also stellt sich nochmal determiniert
ist und im wald über determination ist
die auch durch mich determiniert ist
greift das prinzip der alternativen
möglichkeiten nicht du hast auch schon
dargestellt dass also wirklich nicht
sein muss dass das prinzip der
alternativen möglichkeiten auch der
grund für das handeln ist der könnte
auch in mir liegen aber mit ihm doch
zusammenstimmen eine gewisse weiß ja und
das hat vor allem wird gesehen diese
differenzen und die haben die anderen
nicht gesehen offensichtlich
diese arten zu gehen
ein anwalt der schweiz
zunächst hatte ich zum einen muss man
aushalten
seit stunden unter sind eben nicht
ausgerichtet
ja also das was anfängt wird auch tun so
fremd seien
ist das also eine intuition ist nicht
alles heißt und er gibt es irgendetwas
was wichtig ist wenn wir glauben dass
das prinzip der hat dann interpretiert
und hersteller auch dann ein
verbessertes prinzip vor
es wäre es ein anderes das ist was sie
vorschlagen aber es ist nicht
ausgeschlossen dass frankfurt fünf
verschiedene möglichkeiten offen
das wäre vielleicht eine möglichkeit die
fälle zu reparieren
da müsste man alle fixieren und das ist
dann wirklich klappt aber jahre also
franken würde dem zustimmen
also man kann die sache wenn man sie ein
bisschen ein bisschen platzierte
formuliert und pannen haben zwei meldung
ist tot und dann dort zwischen einer
phobie zu trennen
irgendwie zu handeln und die frau fällt
bald erkannte man ein englisch als
krankheit
jemand dazu zwingen irgendwie zu handeln
und da hat man wieder diese motivation
nach den paketen oder ist der
unterschiedlichkeit keines von den
anderen unterscheiden also dass wir dann
betrachten wir sind wichtiger punkt also
ich konnte diese aber nur beispiele
damit der unterschied klar ist und dann
ist natürlich im einzelfall in frage
kann man wirklich so scharf trennen
zwischen problem und einfach nur einen
schlechten charakter oder gehen die
sachen vielleicht mehr her
also es gibt einen grund warum mich
nicht praktischer philosophie helfen
kann es theoretisch also stimmen
einzelfalles jetzt mal total schwer es
um die beschreibung zutreffen man sollte
sich hüten da vor sich da also in
moralischen fragen rechtlich verstehe
ich dass man sich dass man als richter
also das ist wichtiges recht gesetzt
waren aber die moralische fragen sondern
das interesse zurück weist mich klar ist
woher kommt es an
also es kann natürlich sein kann
es kann sein das perfekte
voraussetzungen hatte und einfach durch
grottige moralisch verwerfliche
entscheidungen dazu gekommen sind frauen
gerecht und sagen dann scheinen waldrand
und des 20 videos sein dass die umstände
und die eltern und vielleicht auch
bestimmte kubin oder anlagen ich hatte
mich dazu bringen jetzt frauen zu sein
oder erlebnisse die mich zum scheitern
gebracht also das negativ
ich würde den standardprodukten im
einzigen fall die entscheidung zu müssen
ist ist es jetzt wirklich bis der
zwischen punk und gothic vielleicht ein
bisschen in der anfangsszene verein
erfahren wir aus kurz ist nur wichtig
wenn er nicht anders handeln konnte als
der handel ist ja dann moralisch
verhandlungen ob wir das seine meisten
fall erkennen können ist in gange sind
spannender kann und natürlich meine
mannschaft al-wazir ist ein manchmal
auch eher davon ab welche verbrechen
begeht und es ist diese eher gefährlich
kann natürlich sein dass der nachbar
damit anders kann als sonst sein hier
ist und vielleicht tut ihm unrecht aber
okay wir hatten noch eine meldung
[Musik]
so fing das an
sprechen
von der cdu gegeben fast gar keinen fall
schon
ich wollte dich an den rechten also nie
könnte der vermieter also damit seien
wieder derselbe sie stellen ihr können
und was macht es unter logische und eine
logische und logischer erkennen ist im
auto logisches politiker nicht
also ich kann verfechter des prinzips
alter die möglichkeit gesagt oder das
auch besser defensives alternativen kann
und trotzdem gemeint haben dass wir ihm
alles sind beim herausdrücken können ob
man wirklich machen
es ist kompatibel warum weil die eine
aussage des theologischen aussagen also
um zu erkennen ist betrachte keine
aussage über das was wir können
feststellen könnten nicht verstehen kann
das betrifft unsere unserer kenntnis
vermögen und die andere frage ist wissen
frage darüber was wirklich sache ist das
tatsächlich der fall ist
und das ist ganz wichtig aber es ist gut
dass in frage kommen weil es eine
wichtige unterscheiden also
epidemiologie und
oder logik vielleicht schon fast ein
bisschen logik spielt auch eine rolle
und marco jetzt erklärst du uns mal wer
der black ist und der jones 4
ich lese ich lese nach vorne
also nehmen wir nun an das black das ist
verrückter wissenschaftler der johns
black ist dieser wissenschaft als ein
böser böser wissenschaftler böse böse
nehmen wir nun an das blatt zu keinem
zeitpunkt seine absichten offen legen
muss was also macht vor hat weil jones 4
dass es eben einer dieser beispiele aus
eigenen gründen entscheidet genau die
handlung zu vollziehen und wirklich
diese handlung forciert die black von
ihm zu tun verlangt in diesem fall
scheint es klar zu sein dass jones 4
genau dieselbe moralische verantwortung
für sein tun trägt die ertragen würde
wäre black nicht bereit maßnahmen zu
ergreifen um abzusichern dass er so
handelt es würde nun es würde völlig
unverständlich seien aufgrund der
tatsache dass er nicht anders hätte
handeln können jones 4 für seine
handlung zu entschuldigen oder ihm das
lob vorzuenthalten wozu ihn
normalerweise seine handlung berechtigt
diese tatsache spielt überhaupt keine
rolle beim zustandekommen der von ihm
vollzogenen handlung
er hätte auch ohne das bestehen dieser
tatsache so gehandelt
in der tat geschah alles so als ob es
ohne blacks anwesenheit in dieser
situation ohne dessen bereitschaft sich
einzumischen geschehen werden
muss ich entscheiden demografie leckeren
bösen wissenschaftler ist reich b
anhänger und möchte dass die jungs wir
sind wir
um das sicherzustellen ganze natürlich
wie und raumschiff in den geräten
funktions um einfach ein bisschen stunde
zu messungen zu schauen wie so seien die
libration prozess vonstatten geht und
chance und er hat einen film geladen
welches leid den zwei punkte kommen
könnte ob es vielleicht doch nicht
richtig ist die 110 zu wählen dann
drückt einen knopf der nation füllt das
sonntagsessen jones ist fester als wären
hänger die welt der welt im keinen
zweifel auf gesetz black müssen sich
überhaupt nicht aber endlich anders
werden wenn auch nur leicht angezogen
damit schaffte zurück und jones --ein
trotzdem gestiegen
das heißt chance hätte anders handeln
können als die rettung
und trotzdem scheint der moralische
verantwortung seien dafür dass die welt
warum man sich auch weil plötzlich
überhaupt kein heiligenstadt er hätte
sich nur eingemischt wenn schon zum
unentschieden aber 22 jones hauseigenem
hand leben aufgrund einer überlegungen
seines charakters sich dazu entschied
die arktis und erscheint es ging auch
moralisch verantwortlich dafür zu sagen
weil die tatsache dass irgendjemand
dasteht und einer deutschen bühne wenn
sich jemand anderes entscheidende frage
ist das ist die frage das ist eben die
frage ob es tatsächlich relevant ist
ich denke mal wenn man nur die situation
als solche nimmt ohne was wäre wenn und
so sowie zum querschnitte momentaufnahme
und logisch dann ist es ganz klar dass
es so ist und jetzt können wir das doch
mal die diskussion geben also wie sehen
sie das also ist es wirklich so
unrelevant diese umstände oder was wäre
denn wenn jones wusste dass da der black
ist der das tät in diesem fall das
systemische dimension dich wieder
reinbringen aber die frage die sich hier
stellt haben ist die ästhetische
dimension wirklich und theologische
relevant oder kann man nicht sagen die
ästhetische dimension also das wissen um
die umstände das setting innerhalb
dessen sich jones findet kann das nicht
auch konto logisch relevant werden für
die frage nach dem moralischen
zurechenbarkeit wie sehen sie es würden
sie dem zustimmen dem harry frankfurt
dass der jazz hier moralisch
verantwortlich ist für die wahl der
partei seiner seines belieben selbst
wenn black dieser böse professor oder
wissenschaftler im hintergrund sitzt und
ein schreiben würde wieder was anderes
wählen wollte
da ist nicht ein stein schon sagen
auf seite 1
das nächste stärken statt auf 2010
auch gerne darüber bescheid wusste dass
er theoretisch postuliert werden könnte
in der theoretischen so beeinflusst dass
er sein
ich werde mich gar nicht anders
entscheiden weil ich das tue bringt
nichts das ist so der regisseur
tatsächlich nicht so richtig ist genau
wie man es ist egal
auch der dozent jetzt weiß aus welcher
richtung sich entschieden haben
verständlicherweise ist schon ganz genau
weiß er das gemacht hat
also das ist doch unter logisches
signifikanz hat dieses setting zu wissen
oder ob man das nicht noch einbeziehen
muss in die anforderung moralischer
zurechenbarkeit dass das hier sagt man
ja wenn er wenn er anders gehandelt es
noch dazu kommt dann ist er nämlich
schon dann ist er nicht
und das scheint so ein bisschen in
diesem beispiel zu sagen da ist es ja so
okay er weiß dass er beeinflusst wird
und dann ist es ja so und deswegen
entscheidet er sich dann dazu
[Gelächter]
oder hätte er sich überhaupt als frei
angesehen
also hätte er überhaupt gesagt ich bin
noch in dem willens freien kontext oder
hätte er protestiert mir sagt ich
entscheide mich gar nicht ich bin
ähnlich wenn es fragen
das ist von der frage soll man noch ein
zitat nehmen weil wir jetzt zeit nicht
so recht weiß schon voran sind
ich meine das könnte man auch mal als so
ein fazit nehmen jetzt einfach noch mal
was als auch schon gesagt haben ja ich
stehe ist das manchmal vor in diesem
beispiel gibt es hinreichende bedingung
dafür dass jones für die in frage
stehende handlung ausführt welche
handlung er vollzieht liegt nicht in
seiner hand natürlich liegt es in einer
hinsicht in seiner hand ob er
selbstständig handelt oder als resultat
von plex eingreifen das hängt davon ab
welche handlung er selbst zu tun geneigt
ist aber ob er letztlich selbstständig
handelt oder als resultat von plex
eingreifen er vollzieht diese behandeln
zu dem was black von ihm zu tun verlangt
hat er keine alternative wenn er jedoch
selbstständig handelt so dass seine
moralische verantwortung für sein tun
durch die tatsache nicht beeinträchtigt
das black im hintergrund mit finsteren
absichten auf der lauer liegt denn diese
absichten kommt zu keinem zeitpunkt ins
spiel
also über determination so ein bisschen
also ist es ist konnte terminiert
[Applaus]
als das schluss gedanken noch geben und
dann diese hindernisse was manche sagen
hören also in diesem fall ist es
schwieriger deswegen vergab macht
bewusst so kompliziert aber in dem fall
erfahren studenten könnte man jetzt
sagen na gut er ist nicht moralisch
verantwortlich dafür dass er nicht zur
vollen gange ist aber es vielleicht
gerade sparen würde ich dafür dass es
nicht mal versucht und das wäre
vielleicht auch eine andere möglichkeit
in frankfurt zu widersprechen dass man
sagt na also wenn er unterscheidet die
stark genutzt zwischen moralischen
wahrheiten das getan zu haben und der
moralische verantwortung es zumindest
versucht so vielleicht auch hier sollten
zumindest versuchen mich zu gehen
das wäre ein gutes haus arbeitsthema
also zu fragen
stimmen sie damit überein ist er ist er
wirklich moralische verantwortung kann
man nicht doch zeigen die argumentieren
dafür dass dieses setting selbst wenn es
unter logisch dieses prinzip nicht darf
das ist dennoch nicht überzeugen ist das
unserer intuition moralische
zurechenbarkeit da etwas entgegen steht
und wie könnte man das vielleicht mit
dem komplizierten epidemischen argument
vielleicht doch lösen da sind sagt es
gibt eine historische dimension die
notwendig zu moralischer zurechenbarkeit
hinzu gehört und die wird hier verletzt
oder auch mit möglichen gedanken bei
spielen das wäre eine gute idee glaube
ich von der hause bei marco sagst du zum
abschied nochmals übernächsten text
nächste woche werde noch mal da
hinzu kämen gerade verdienen sultan vom
boden oder einen workshop mit ihm und
wir werden da einen text gewesen wäre
heißt die mystery und metaphysik
regierung also sehr wahrscheinlich
gewesen nicht selbst überlegen so wenn
man sie das geheimnis in metaphysische
freiheit und dann geht es um eine
kernthese kommt von innen wagen nämlich
ist das von im budget sind wir haben
alternativen aber die tatsache dass wir
sie haben ist ein echtes geheimnis warum
weil die tatsache dass wir alternativen
haben scheint unvereinbar zusammen mit
determinismus wenn immer schon alles
festgelegt ist durch die naturgesetze
bis die vergangenheit dann scheinbar
keine echte alternative sagt
unterscheide aber auch irgendwann einmal
zu sagen die terrorismus nicht durch
vergangenheit und die besten tipps wie
ich mich entscheide dann scheint meine
entscheidung
und dieses argument verteidigt er sagt
also in beiden fällen können wir
eigentlich wirklich lernen wie wir
handlungsalternativen haben können und
trotzdem und das ist die position des
mysteriums muss die wir auch auf diesem
positionspapier ihn ausgezahlt
dann bis zur nächsten sitzung und noch
ein schönes wort